un mercado cubierto de antioquía al sur
de Turquía un hombre es atacado por los
comerciantes que sospechan que está
saqueando
mientras los soldados que patrullan
intervienen el hombre consigue escapar
en las zonas devastadas por el terremoto
la desconfianza y el miedo se extienden
vigilamos nuestras casas nuestros
vehículos los saqueadores nos roban
estamos devastados es como una pesadilla
en las calles los cajeros automáticos
han sido destruidos bien por el
terremoto bien por los saqueadores a
través de esta puerta rota Se ha vaciado
en la tienda de teléfonos móviles solo
en la provincia de hatay decenas de
personas han sido detenidas en posesión
de grandes sumas de dinero en efectivo
aparatos electrónicos joyas o tarjetas
bancarias
Si la gente viene a llevarse pañales
comida o bebida es comprensible porque
hace días que no llega ayuda Pero hay
gente que viene a llevarse cocinas o
cafeteras esta tienda de aquí ha sido
saqueada
los saqueos no son El único problema de
seguridad el sábado el ejército
austríaco y dos grupos alemanes
suspendieron sus operaciones de rescate
alegando el deterioro de la situación de
seguridad con enfrentamientos entre
grupos que incluye el antiroteos
la situación de seguridad se está
volviendo un poco más tensa debido a que
se está acabando la comida se está
acabando el agua y la gente está
buscando provisiones la esperanza que
antes tenía la gente se está
desvaneciendo cada vez más y esa
Esperanza puede entonces convertirse
también en
el sábado el gobierno Turco decretó que
los fiscales pueden retener a los
presuntos saqueadores durante siete días
en lugar de cuatro como parte del Estado
de emergencia declarado tras el
terremoto